[MUSIC PLAYING]
YIGIT BOYAR: Hello and
welcome, everybody.
My name is Yigit Boyar,
and I'm the technical lead
for Architecture Components.
Thank you.
So today, we are going
to talk about what is
new in Architecture Components.
But before we start
with them, let's
look at what we have been doing
in the last two, three years.
So three years ago, we
were talking to developers.
And they were saying,
oh, Android development
is so hard, so hard.
We're like, what is hard
about Android development?
And they started listing things
like Lifecycles, Persistence.
Like, a lot of things
were just hot, you know?
So we needed to pick something.
We said, OK, we're going to
first create an architecture
guidance.
And we're going to tackle
some of the major problems we
think are important.
So we started with
Lifecycles and Persistence.
Two years ago at I/O,
we announced them.
Soon after, we
have added Paging,
because we realized
people struggle with that,
making it efficient.
And then in last year's I/O,
we have added WorkManager
and Navigation to the flock.
All these five
libraries together
had more than 150
releases in two years.
That's like a release
every five days.
And based on the latest survey,
70% of professional developers
use one of those libraries
in their applications.
So thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
This is, like, a really
amazing adoption number for us.
And let's look at
how we're doing it.
So every project
starts this life
with an early access program.
So once we know what
we are planning to do,
we send it to some
developers, ask for feedback.
After we are comfortable
with that feedback,
we release a public alpha,
which is when we are still
developing it actively, but
it is ready to show everyone.
After some time, we become
happy with the functionality
and the APIs, and
we call it beta.
When we call
something beta, that
means the API will
not change anymore.
So you can write code, and that
code will still keep compiling.
And eventually, the
library becomes stable.
And soon after the
library becomes stable,
we always go back to
alpha and then beta.
So the cycle keeps turning.
We heard that, like, many people
are unhappy because everything
is in alpha all the time.
This is because of it.
You can happily use the
latest stable version.
But we want to
develop in the open,
and we want this
rapid iteration cycle.
And all of this is possible
thanks to the community.
So we do a lot of User
Experience Research.
We talk to developers.
They keep these Developer
Diaries while they work.
They do real regular
work at work.
They log what they are doing,
and tell us how it is going.
We do a lot of
one-on-one interviews
with developers to better
understand the problems.
We do Early Access Programs
so that before showing it
to everybody, we can talk to
a closer group, more in-depth,
and get initial feedback.
Issue Tracker, where you report
your bugs and feature requests,
is very important for us.
This is what we use to
prioritize features and bugs.
Last but not least,
we closely follow
things like Reddit,
StackOverflow,
to see what the
community is thinking.
So yesterday we have
announced that it's going
to be Kotlin first for Android.
So this means we are not going
to just release ktx libraries.
We are going to release more
Kotlin-focused libraries.
Maybe some of them will
be written in Kotlin
to take advantage of the
better language features.
So it means some of the APIs
will first target Kotlin,
and then will also support
the Java programming language.
So during today, when I talk
about these new features,
you will see a lot of Kotlin.
OK, so let's start
the libraries.
And we will start with the
oldest library we have,
Data Binding.
So if you don't
know Data Binding,
Data Binding is our
declarative UIs inside XML.
It tries to bridge the gap
between your code and your XML.
So if you have a
layout like this,
if you put these
layout tags around it,
you'll get a Binding class.
If you add variables as
inputs to that layout,
they become setters and
getters in this Binding class.
And then you can use these
variables in your layout
and declare what
you want to show.
And Data Binding takes
care of showing it.
This last one year, we've been
heavily focused on the tooling
part of Data Binding.
So we have significantly
improved the compilation speed.
It's now 20% faster while we
run the annotation processor.
We added support for
distributed grade of cache,
so that if you're
using in your company,
you benefit from your peers
compiling the projects.
Last but not least,
in 3.5, now we
have an incremental annotation
processor for Data Binding.
It's experimental, so you need
to turn it on with this flag.
So please give it a try, and
let us know how it works.
So other part of Data
Binding is tooling
integration, which is Studio.
So we did a lot of work here.
So one of the things
we've improved
is how the live class
generation works.
So on the left here, I have
this Binding class associated
with the layout on the right.
And if I want to
access the stacks view,
I can just go ahead
and give it an ID.
So when my view has
an ID, it becomes
a field in the Binding class.
And here, immediately,
without compiling the project,
I have that field in
that Binding object.
So we don't need to wait.
[APPLAUSE]
So if you're using
Data Binding, this
is not how we update
the views, right?
You can also do it
with a variable.
That's actually how you
will do it in Data Binding.
So we go ahead, change it.
We add this header as a
variable to the layout.
As you can see,
autocomplete works.
We get rid of the ID,
because we don't need it.
Instead, we are just going
to say text is header.
As you can see, code
completion works here, too.
On the left, it
immediately turned red.
So just go ahead and fix it.
So all of this works without
waiting for compilation.
[APPLAUSE]
So another important
thing is refactoring.
So I have a user object
here on the left, which
is a variable on the right.
And in one of the
expressions, I accessed that
and call a function
on that user object.
But if I go to the
class and say I'm
going to rename this
function, and I'm going
to call it, say, CombinedName.
So as soon as I make this
change and it entered,
Android Studio updates
my binding [INAUDIBLE]
automatically for me.
And you can do the
same thing from XML,
and it will update your code.
Last but not least, we know
Data Binding error messages
has been a huge problem.
That, like, you will have any
problem in your compilation,
you will get 1,000 errors.
So we fixed that problem.
We have also added a
section in your output
that is specific to
Data Binding errors,
so you can easily discover them.
So similar to Data
Binding, like,
how do we access
views on Androids?
Let's look at all
the options we have.
We're going to
evaluate them in terms
of elegance, the
compile time safety,
and the build speed impact.
So first, we have the
good old findViewById.
It's not elegant,
it's very verbose.
Doesn't provide any
compile time safety.
You don't know what
type you're receiving.
But it doesn't have any build
speed impact, so that's good.
You could use DataBinding,
which provides a really nice API
with the compile time safety.
But it draws an
annotation processor,
so it does slow down your build.
You could be using
Butterknife similarly.
It's another
annotation processor,
so it's going to
slow down your build.
Now if you're in
Kotlin, you could
use Kotlin Synthetic accesses.
It provides partial
compile time safety,
is a really beautiful
API, and also it
doesn't have any
build speed impact.
But we are looking for this.
Like something that
has a green checkmark
in all of these things.
It should be possible.
And we don't need to look
far to discover this.
So if you look at
this Data Binding,
we see a lot of people using
Data Binding like this.
They put IDs through the Views,
just to get this binding class
on the right.
No variables, no expressions.
So why don't we just
call this View Binding?
So View Binding is
a new feature that's
going to be available
in Android Studio 3.6.
That's the next version.
[APPLAUSE]
So now let's go back to
the previous example.
We had these Layout texts.
They're not necessary.
We don't have variables.
So we can get rid of it.
This is just a
regular layout XML.
So if you're headed
for more activity,
we will access it like this.
But you don't want
this findViewById.
So control F it out.
And instead, we can use
the generated Binding
class inflated, and
then setContentView.
And now we are going to
have all of the Views
with IDs as public final
fields in that object.
So you get perfect
compile time safety,
because if the idea with the
correct type doesn't exist,
your code will just not compile.
And you can also
use it from Java.
[APPLAUSE]
So thank you.
All of these Binding classes are
generated by the Android Gradle
plug-in.
So it doesn't need to do
any extra work unless you
change a layout file.
And if you change a layout
file, only that file gets
invalidated.
So it's very fast doing
incremental compilation.
It's 100% compile time safe,
so if your code compiles,
you know those views exist
in the right layouts.
It has full Studio integration,
similar to what I have
shown for Data Binding earlier.
And speaking of Data
Binding, it is completely
compatible with Data Binding.
In fact, if you're using Data
Binding just to access Views,
you can turn it off and
turn on View Binding.
And your code will
compile as is.
OK.
Now we're going to
move to Lifecycle.
And I'm going to invite Sergey
to tell us more about it.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
SERGEY VASILINETS: Thanks Yigit.
Good morning, everyone.
My name is Sergey, and I
will give a quick update
on Lifecycles.
So what we did two
years ago is, first
of all, introduced a
way to observe events
from your Fragments
or Activities,
so you know where it started
or resumed, and so on.
We introduced
ViewModels, that is,
retained state across
configuration changes.
Kind of a starting point
for your non-UI pod.
And lastly, LiveData
is just observable
that have a good
default behavior
to observe with Lifecycle.
But before proceeding
to new stuff,
we have to talk about that.
After I/O, I read on
the internet this.
And I was like, what's going on?
I don't agree with that at all.
And I have to explain now
why this confusion exists,
and why it's not true.
So the picture is
kind of like that.
So it was going to be a full
explanation at the beginning.
So you have your stuff.
You put your stuff into
ViewModel or a SavedState.
Configuration Change happens.
You go to your
ViewModel or SavedState
and grab your
stuff out of there.
Is it the similar mechanisms?
Well, actually, no.
So let's take a closer look
only on SavedState part.
Same set up.
You put your stuff
into the SavedState.
When we talked about
Configuration Change, well,
actual purpose of SavedState
is not Configuration Changes.
It is created to help
you with process depth.
Because the system manager's
application in the background
may decide, well, we need this
memory for some other task,
and kill your application.
But because Android wants to
provide nice user experience,
what we do is, once the
application has restarted,
we give you hints.
The SavedState
gives us hints here.
How to create the state that
you had before, and the user's
seen before.
So how does it actually work?
And then one step deeper.
So once you put
your SavedState--
[INAUDIBLE] a SavedState,
what actually happens,
SavedState travels
to the system server.
System server is a
separate process.
So there is, like, this travel
across process boundaries.
And this gives us very
specific restrictions
on what is a SavedState.
It's not the stuff.
It's the data.
It's parcelable data.
It's just what we call
a serializable Android.
Or primitive types.
And also we have this data
limit on the size of it,
because otherwise system
can't keep, like, gigabytes
of data for every application.
And serialization actually
takes time as well.
So it just won't work.
So this is a SavedState.
So let's take a look
on our ViewModels.
Well in a contrast
to SavedState,
ViewModel always lives
in the process memory.
Then it never leaves it.
So Configuration Change doesn't
affect it anyhow at all.
It just-- memory is continuous.
Your ViewModel is still there.
Process doesn't die,
so your stuff is there.
So however when
processes are restarted--
well, it's in process memory.
Process dies.
Everything there goes away.
And then the application
is restarted.
From a ViewModel perspective,
you have nothing.
So you can see they handle
different situations.
And ViewModel are for
keeping references
to your non-serializable
things, like network requests
in-flight, or database queries.
Well, it doesn't mean
that you actually
to write these things there.
But it kind of provides
the scope for them.
And other things that
you can keep there
is big objects like
a long list of data
you queried from database and
you need to keep somewhere.
Or images that are relevant only
for that fragment specifically.
While SavedState is this UI-bits
like selection and scroll
state.
And navigation state.
This is, like, more
interesting for us.
What does this mean?
So once you show, let's say,
a screen with user profile,
you want to know what
user you showed last time.
So you need to keep user ID
in this navigation state.
So we'll see this
example in a second.
So as you see, ViewModel and
SavedState work together.
They shouldn't be opposed.
So let's see on
this user example.
So your ViewModel
will look like this.
You have a user.
And then you have a LiveData
of this information.
How you would do this
ViewModel plus SavedState
and all the way?
Well, this is fairly
boilerplate-ish.
In onCreate, you go to
bundle, parse the information
from the bundle.
Plus the ViewModel.
In SavedState,
you go in reverse.
Filler, boilerplate.
And what we did,
we introduced a way
to contribute the SavedState
from ViewModel right away.
So now you can receive this
SavedStateHandle object right
in your ViewModel constructor.
And this object will allow
you to access SavedState right
into your ViewModel.
So what is this?
It's very simple.
It's map-like object,
meaning that it
has very straightforward API.
You just put stuff, and
get it once you put it--
later when your
application is recreated,
ViewModel is created.
It receives the
SavedState handle.
The information that
you put by the key
will be available
to you again, so you
can query by the same key.
We also give you
nice convenience API.
If you use LiveData, you can--
instead of just .getData you
can observe it in a usual way.
And because SavedState is
mutable, because otherwise
it would be a constant.
No need to save it.
We can give you a
mutable LiveData
and you can write as
you would do usually.
So last slide on this theme
is provided by my manager,
actually.
SavedState is not your database.
No matter which API you
use, old uncreate and unsave
in SavedState.
Or this new convenience API.
Or fragment arguments.
Underlying mechanisms
are the same.
So you still have
this restrictions
about what you can put
there on the size limit.
So it won't just work.
And we go to the other thing.
So continues everywhere,
Lifecycle aren't exceptions.
Yesterday, we had a talk
about Coroutines in Lifecycle.
If you missed it, you can
find it on the internet.
We introduced a bunch of new
APIs, looking for feedback.
And we kind of paid our debts
in other fields of Lifecycles.
For example, some
conversions were broken
for a long time for LiveData.
So you can see it doesn't
look like natural Kotlin code.
And now it does.
You can have this land
after observe all.
Similar transformations
looked very unnatural,
because we had this static
method on transformations.
And you know, it's just not
the way you do that in Kotlin.
Instead of that, you
have extension functions.
We did that.
And last thing is the
ViewModels initialization.
We kind of forced it to
have this lateinit var.
And it's a bit of a [INAUDIBLE].
People are getting
worried when you see it.
It's for a reason.
Or now the ViewModels.
Models So now it's
with [INAUDIBLE],,
you have very concise index.
You just initialize your
ViewModel, and that is it.
[APPLAUSE]
And actually that is
it for Lifecycles.
And I hand out for Sumir, who
is going to present WorkManager
and a [INAUDIBLE].
[APPLAUSE]
SUMIR KATARIA: Hi, everyone.
My name is Sumir Kataria,
and I am an engineer
on the Android team.
I want to talk to you a little
bit about WorkManager today.
For those of you who
don't know, WorkManager
is a background processing
library for work
that is specifically deferrable,
meaning that it doesn't
have to be executed right away.
This is also work
that's persistent.
So it can go across
app restarts.
It can go across
device restarts.
So it needs to be persistent.
This is work that's
constraint-based,
so you can have work
that only triggers
when you have a network
connection, for example.
Or other constraints.
And finally, this is work
that's backwards compatible.
So it goes all the way back
to Ice Cream Sandwich, API 14.
Before I go to,
actually, top priorities,
we released a stable
version of WorkManager 1.0
a couple of months ago.
So I want to thank everybody
who participated in the alpha,
beta, Early Access Program.
Thank you very much.
So our top priorities moving
forward, there's three of them
that I'm going to
talk about today.
One is performance
and compatibility.
The next is testing.
And finally, building
for the future.
So things that are
more forward-looking.
So let's talk about
performance and compatibility.
The first thing that
I want to talk about
is on-demand initialization.
It's available now in alpha,
so please check it out.
So one of the things that
you might have noticed
with WorkManager
is that it needs
to be initialized when
your app starts up.
This is, more or less, a
hard requirement currently.
And this on-demand
initialization
will allow you to
start WorkManager only
when you need it,
which is really
good for avoiding critical
hot paths like app startup.
This is not something that you
need to worry about anymore.
You can just use it when
you actually need it.
Let's take a look
at how this looks.
So right now, you might
have your Application class.
So you might have customized
it so you have a MyApp.
And in WorkManager 2.1
alpha, you can extend--
or actually implement--
Configuration.Provider,
override this method,
and this returns
a WorkManager configuration.
So this is all
WorkManager needs to know
on where to get this data.
Now, currently in
WorkManager 2.0,
you get
WorkManager.getInstance, and you
don't provide any arguments.
And starting in 2.1, if you
provide this context argument,
this is WorkManager's signal,
OK, if I'm not initialized,
I can go to the application
object, get the configuration,
and do a lazy initialization
when I'm needed.
So that's all it is.
It's very simple.
The second thing I
want to talk about here
is Google Play
Services integration.
And this is coming soon.
So this basically will allow
you to have better performance
on pre-Marshmallow devices.
And it's totally optional.
You don't really
need to integrate it
if you don't want it.
And if you do want
to integrate it,
it's just a simple Gradle
dependency that you add.
Nothing else, because
there's no API changes.
Under the hood, it'll see
if you have Play Services.
If you're using it, it'll use
it on pre-Marshmallow devices.
And compatibility improvements.
This is an ongoing
project for us.
And this is not something
that you'll necessarily
see in our code base
or in our releases,
but it's stuff that we
do behind the scenes.
And I want to talk a
little bit about it.
So we've noticed that there are
a few differences in devices
and manufacturers.
For example, if you go to the
Recents of your device, and you
swipe away an app.
On a stock Android device
or on a Pixel device,
you'll notice that the
process gets killed.
But on some devices, you
might see that the app
gets force-stopped.
And force stop is a
really destructive action.
In the case of force stop, your
jobs get stopped and wiped out,
actually.
Your alarms got wiped out.
You no longer receive FCMs.
Force stop is a very
destructive action.
So we're working with OEMs to
have a consistent app close
behavior here.
We want to make sure that
everybody has the same app
close behavior, which is
really good for libraries
like WorkManager, which
operate in the background.
The next thing I want to
talk about is testing.
When we launched WorkManager
a couple of months ago,
we kind of had a problem
with roboelectric support,
in that it didn't work.
We fixed it.
It's out and stable,
sorry about that.
And also, now we have an alpha
unit testing for workers.
So basically you can
create your workers
using one of these two
classes, TestWorkerBuilder
or TestListenableWorkerBuilder.
And you can just use them by
using the doWork or startWork
method as is appropriate.
So let's take a look
at that in action.
So let's say you
have a WorkRequest.
You can use a TestWorkerBuilder,
and you can say,
create that WorkRequest from
a given context and a given
executor on which it will run.
You just build it.
So this gives you a
worker class back.
And then you can call
the doWork method, which
is a method you've
already overwritten,
and get its result. You
can assert a result.
You can check the
state of your app,
make sure everything's fine.
So that's how you would
unit test a worker.
If you're using a listenable
worker, same thing.
You start with a WorkRequest.
And you use a
TestListenableWorkerBuilder,
and you can say, create a
worker using that request.
You build it.
And same thing.
Instead of calling doWork in
this case, you call startWork.
Remember that listenable
workers are asynchronous
and control their own execution.
So you don't need to
specify an executor here.
And startWork returns
a listenable future,
so you just call a blocking
get-on in this case.
And you assert that everything
is the way you want it to be.
You can even provide
more arguments.
So you can say something like,
here's the input data for it.
Here's the runAttemptCount
that you're currently on.
Here's the tags that you
have for this worker.
And the last thing
I want to talk about
is building for the future.
And this is-- in
particular, we want
to have foreground service
support in WorkManager.
And this is very
much in progress.
So this is not ready.
This is-- later in the
year, you'll probably
see something about this.
But the basic idea
is, what if you
could do work in the foreground
using the WorkManager API?
And this is particularly useful.
I was talking to
someone this morning.
They wanted to do a
long-running upload.
WorkManager and
JobScheduler both give you
a 10-minute slice of
time to do an upload
or whatever work you have.
But what if it goes
longer than that?
You can use a program
service for that,
and WorkManager can
make it easier for you.
So because this is a
foreground service,
your app will show
a notification.
Talk to us about it in the
sandbox if you're interested.
We want to hear
what everybody has
to contribute to this, what use
cases you have, and so forth.
And now I'd like to turn
it over to Danny, for Room.
[APPLAUSE]
DANIEL SANTIAGO:
Thank you, Samir.
Hey, my name is Daniel
Santiago, and I'll
be talking a little
bit about Room.
But before we get to what's
new at Room, what is Room?
Well, Room is our SQLite
object mapping library.
And it basically creates
a bunch of code for you,
based on some annotation,
so that you can easily
access your data objects
with a SQLite database.
Let's do a quick recap
on how this looks.
Imagine we're making
a music application.
We're going to be saving
some songs on a database.
We start by having a data class.
We call it Song.
It has some ID, a URL.
For Room, to let
know that you want
to have a table for this
Entity, you annotate it
with the Entity annotation.
You let it know of
its unique identifier.
Now in a database, if you want
to get the data out of it,
you write a normal SQL query.
SELECT star FROM Song.
But to let Room
know that you want
to link this query
with that data class,
you actually put it on a method.
That returns a list
of songs, and it's
annotated with a Query.
Now you don't throw these
methods all over the place.
You actually put them on what
we call a data access subject.
And if this is just an
interface or an abstract class,
annotate it with @Dao.
Now to link these together,
you have your MusicDatabase,
it extends RoomDatabase.
It has a @Database annotation.
And then you let it know of its
entities, which in this case
will be the song.
And the Daos are
just getter method.
In a nutshell, it kind
of looks like this.
You have your database, your
Daos, and your entities.
And your application interacts
with all of these things.
Now let's get to the good stuff.
So something new that's in
Room 2.1 is Coroutine support.
In Room 2.0, if you tried to add
a suspend method to your Dao,
because you have a Kotlin
app, you're using Coroutines,
and you probably want to do
your heavy work asynchronously,
you usually add
your suspend method.
Room would freak out.
He wouldn't know what to do.
He would, nope, can't do that.
And this might lead you to
create wrapper methods, that
are suspend functions
that actually then call
the actual Dao function.
But you can imagine this
doesn't scale very well.
But no worries.
In Room 2.1, you can
actually have Dao methods
that are suspending methods.
Room will generate the
correct code, including
using a background dispatcher.
You can also have suspend
methods with insert,
object, and delete.
And even more so, you can have
suspend implemented methods
that do multiple database
operations, that are annotated
with @Transactions, so that
these database operations are
done automatically.
Even more so, there's
also an extension function
on Room database that will allow
you to start a transaction.
It creates a special
Coroutine context
that you can use to also perform
multiple database operations.
Now another new feature we added
in Room is Full Text Search.
Full Text Search is
an extension in SQLite
to be able to create tables to
efficiently search for data.
Thinking back on our
music app, imagine
we're trying to create
a search functionality.
We want to search for
songs, given a phrase.
If we were to do
this in Room 2.0,
we would have to
write a Dao method.
Kind of like this.
Doesn't look great, you
have this huge WHERE clause.
It has all the columns, like.
It's not great.
But no worries.
In Room 2.1, if
you want an Entity
to be able to be
backed by an Fts table,
you simply use the
Fts annotation.
And now this greatly
simplifies your query,
because you can start using
the MATCH expression, which
is way more efficient.
Speaking of--
[APPLAUSE]
Yeah.
Thanks.
Speaking of simplifying
things, Database Views
is another way to simplify
your database operation.
So Database Views are
kind of like tables,
where everywhere you
reference a table,
you can reference a view.
But they're different because
you cannot insert data
into views.
To put it differently,
they're kind of like queries
with a given name.
Let's think, again, back
to our music application.
This time, we want to
show a list of albums.
And these albums have some
aggregated information.
The total number of songs, and
the total time in the album.
And thinking back, how
we started using Room,
we have a simple data class with
the information that we need.
Now, in Room 2.1, instead
of having a BigQuery,
you can actually annotate your
data class with @DatabaseView.
And instead of making a table,
you'll create a view out of it.
And then to specify how
we get this information,
you put your BigQuery
in the annotation.
And you can see,
it's a BigQuery.
It has segregating information.
But the important
thing is that now you
can use this view or entity
as if it was another table.
And you can see
here, we also have
another ORDER BY,
which you know,
makes your operations easier.
[APPLAUSE]
Nice.
We've been also adding more
support for Rx in Room,
since we know people like Rx.
In Room 2.1, you can
have insert, update,
and delete method that return
Completable, Maybe, and Single.
And even more newer,
we also added support
for returning Rx tag
on Query-annotated Dao
methods that perform
write statements,
such as update,
insert, and delete.
So for those queries that
are more complicated,
but you still want to
use Rx, you can do that.
Now, that's some of
the new things in Room.
But we still have a
lot more work to do.
One of the most immediate
things we want to do
is have an incremental
annotation processor.
This will greatly improve
the build performance
for those of you using Room,
or for those of you who
might start to use Room.
We also know that relationship
is another area of improvement.
We only have a single
annotation for @Relation.
And it helps you
with one to many,
but we feel like we
can do many to many.
Even maybe using a jump table.
So that's one area we
are trying to explore.
We also know that
migrations are not so great.
Like, when you use Room, it
creates the tables for you.
But then when you
migrate, you also
have to call the
CREATE statement.
We feel like most of
the migration operations
can be done with
some code generation,
such as adding a new table
or renaming a column.
Things like that.
Last but not least, as we take
a look at Kotlin and Coroutines,
we are keeping our
eye on their APIs.
And we'll be able to add
support for Channels and Flow.
Thanks.
So back to Yigit, who will be
talking to you about Paging.
[APPLAUSE]
YIGIT BOYAR: Thanks, Danny.
OK, let's talk about Paging.
So if you don't
know Paging, Paging
is our library to load large
lists into RecyclerView lazily.
And it works with
multiple data source.
It works with Room,
Realm, Retrofit,
whatever kind of place where
you can pull the data from.
For the next version
of Paging, our focus
is on networking
and error handling.
So we heard this loud
and clear, that it
is kind of hard to channel
your errors from your network
back into your UI.
So we are working on a new
pipeline to enable this,
We'll also add support to change
those pages as you pull them,
so you can inject headers
and footers or filter them.
Last but not least, we
are going to improve
the support for RxJava and
add support for Coroutines.
So these are all in the
next version of Paging.
We are about to start an
Early Access Program for it.
So we are doing an
Early Access Program
because we significantly
changed the API, so we
want to get good feedback.
And later in the summer, you
should expect an alpha version.
All right, Navigation.
Navigation is a library we
released in a previous I/O.
It helps you with
your in app UI flows.
So you can easily show a graph,
control how the user should
navigate, et cetera.
So a couple months ago,
Navigation became stable.
And we already started working
on the next version, which
is already out.
And in this next version,
we have a new feature
for ViewModels where
you can scope them
to a Navigation Graph.
This is amazing.
Where you have things
like sign-up flows
that's composed of
multiple screens,
you can just have one
ViewModel for that whole scope.
[APPLAUSE]
And other features, you
can now navigate by URI,
so you don't need
to have the IDs.
And you can finally use dialogs
as navigation destinations.
[APPLAUSE]
So these are all in 2.1.
But another big upcoming
feature for Navigation
is support for dynamically
delivered modules.
Now it's not ready yet.
This is going to take a
couple of months to implement.
But it's going to be
available in Navigation
so that you can just
navigate as if everything
is inside the application,
without thinking
about dynamic features.
So to learn more
about all of these,
join us later today at 1:30 in
the Jetpack Navigation talk.
OK, so if you're, like, maybe
new to these things, or trying
to get started
with Kotlin, trying
to get started with
Architecture Components,
we just released a
new course on Udacity.
This is, like, a 10-course
session, completely online,
that teaches you how to
write a modern Android
application using Kotlin
and Architecture Components.
So this is a great
resource to get started
with these technologies.
You can always find detailed
documentation on our website.
And if you want to be involved
further in our process,
you can go to this URL and
see how you can participate
in our development flow.
Thank you.
[MUSIC PLAYING]